what i will say is i think i finally
understand when people get sick of like
tolkien's pages and pages of description
for things and their eyes just glaze
over because jane austen does the same
thing with a lot of her dialogue you
would be surprised how easy it is to
miss reading some classic authors if you
don't just go out of your way to do it
so
that is what i did and i picked up jane
austen's emma on the recommendation of
my jane austen obsessed friend who said
that this is uh objectively unarguably
jane austen's best book uh and i trust
her on that and i and i assume that
there's no bias uh and that no one
disagrees with her but before we get
started tell me your favorite classic
novel down in the comments below mine
would probably be 100 years of solitude
by gabrielle garcia marquez or 1984 by
george orwell i just love the ideas that
both of those discuss and i want to be
clear this is not what i usually read
not only because it was published over
200 years ago but because it is a
romance novel and i have read books with
romances and i've read books that are
about romances but doing a romance novel
in particular
not really my thing usually but a book
this much about romance is kind of a new
thing for me so with all of that take
everything i say with you know a
truckload of salt because i am not an
expert on jane austen or her writings or
other writings like this
anyways
what is emma about
emma is about a girl called emma who
doesn't want to marry herself but likes
matchmaking the people around her except
uh she's kind of crap at it and keeps
making everyone around her miserable
through her attempts to pair people
together and messing it up almost every
single time and then at the end she
marries a man called and i kid you not
mr nightly because you know
knight in shining armor probably okay
he's not perfect but he also doesn't
want to marry just like her and who
would have thought that these two people
who definitely don't want to marry end
up marrying each other in the end
having finished this book i can also
conclude that jane austen at some point
in her life must have had a really
erotic ballroom dance with someone and
has just been
never able to let it go because
apparently that is just the pinnacle of
flirtation
the best way for me to capture what
reading this was like was you know those
why a novels where like every character
is snarky and witty and can always clap
back because the author seemingly thinks
that those the only interesting types of
characters well it's like that but good
because conversation without
understanding is kind of a big theme in
this book and from what i know a lot of
her other writings as well you know
people will say a lot of stuff but not
what they truly mean and that's a big
source of the conflict and emma's
mistakes in this book because
conversation is more treated as like an
intellectual battle where you're trying
to outwit the other person to take the
high ground in a way and so you get a
lot of subtext and characters trying to
interpret one another which results in a
lot of those types of characters at the
same time it's really taking pot shots
at english society at the time where
expressing yourself kind of
authentically and your emotions was a
little bit frowned upon you were kind of
expected to do it a little more subtly
emma is an aware critique of that
society and the frustrations and even
the pain that comes with that and so our
main character is kind of scandalous
because she is so openly spoken about
how she feels and what she wants but she
is also manipulative and sly and witty
and that comes out in her dialogue with
a lot of that clever phrasing i think
what really worked for me was the tone
of the book it's very cozy like you're
never too worried anything terrible is
going to happen and it's kind of comedic
it's a little bit satirical and it lets
you kind of just lean into the
characters and go along for the ride
with them
which is not something i usually read
but because that tone and satire comes
so much from the historical context of
when this was written and what it was
commentating on i think me having a bit
of knowledge of that time period really
enriched my experience with the story
and if you don't necessarily have that
you may not pick up on some of those
layers to it and you may not enjoy it as
much and that's fine these sorts of
stories just come with that context what
i will say is i think i finally
understand when people get sick of like
tolkien's pages and pages of description
for things and their eyes just glaze
over because jane austen does the same
thing with a lot of her dialogue do not
get me wrong the dialogue is brilliant
but characters will take like 200 words
to say something that could have been
said in 10. and again that's part of
that miscommunication thing you know
characters saying things but it's more
about what they can do with the words
than what the actual words are but at
the same time my eyes just kind of
blurred over some of the dialogue which
will just go for pages and pages and
pages back and forth without telling you
sometimes who is speaking uh and you get
to the end of it and i'll feel like
wait what did they actually say across
all of this and it'll be like one small
thing that i pick up you know and it's
because of that dialogue that the two
main characters emma and mr nightly were
so vivid for me they really jumped off
the page with their unique voices if
you've ever read anything by oscar wilde
it's a lot like that it's got that same
clever quippy brilliant you know
snappiness to it but the characters
around those two a little less so there
are a lot of characters in this book uh
that it expects you to remember a lot of
mr this and misses that and some of them
change their names across the story and
it does not help that she does not
really use dialogue or action tags to
tell you who was talking and so there
will be times where you read a passage
and you'll be like wait who said that
and you'll have to go back to make sure
you're tracking who's saying what so
just be prepared for uh wait who was
that was that the priest or the farmer
and how does that person relate to that
person ugh and maybe i just wasn't
paying attention it's possible but
that's not usually a sort of thing that
i suffer from still
i do want to read you just like a little
bit of her writing because she has this
neck for these really clever like
opening lines and prose which are so
iconic ostinian lines i suppose and i'm
gonna open the book so i can pretend i'm
reading from it but the quote's actually
on the phone there because i forgot what
page it was on all right
human nature is so well disposed towards
those who are in interesting situations
that a young person who either marries
or dies is sure to be kindly spoken of
now
isn't that cool i just love that it's
it's got that very
a man and when possession of a great
fortune must be a want of a wife i don't
really want to critique jane austen she
is one of the most well-loved and
well-reputed authors of all time my
thoughts on that front probably not that
helpful i'm just talking about my
experiences with it but i do want to
mention you know coming from kind of the
sci-fi fantasy readership world which i
know a lot of you guys are more
connected to what it is kind of like
it is unlike anything you have probably
read there's a much weaker sense of
place i found in in this book you know
fantasy and sci-fi tends to take a lot
of time easing you into the world at
hand and you can visualize everything
and this book doesn't do that nearly as
much as i said if you don't know much
about english society at the time then
some of these beats may not work for you
as much but do i recommend reading it
it's kind of one of those if you want to
questions you know if you're only
interested in reading science fiction
and fantasy then no probably not but if
you're wanting to more deeply engage
with kind of the english literature
canon because jane austen is a
cornerstone important part of
the stories that we right now and where
that history comes from then she's a
great place to start a great place to
look and if you're wanting to diversify
and increase your knowledge of the
english literature canon which was kind
of what i have been doing i want to read
more diversely and have a deeper
understanding of the culture that i am
swimming in you know for me it's a
personal enrichment thing now i'm not
gonna lie i won't say this book tugging
me along from page to page it's a hefty
book at 160 000 words on its own and i
was glad to be done with it not gonna
lie but i am glad to have read it and i
feel i learned a lot from it
academically and i understand a bit more
about the giants upon the shoulders of
which we stand now so i will leave the
decision in your hands and if you have
read jane austen or read a lot more jane
austen than i have then please tell me
about how right or wrong i am with my
thoughts down in the comments stay nerdy
and i will see you in the future